Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P,
you can call any time. I got a very interesting
voicemail from the Eggman, explaining a
conversation he recently had with someone.
Take a listen to this. This is interesting.
Speaker 8: Hey, Dave, I just had a business
transaction with a conservative Republican
in western New York. Some guy I met, I sold
him something in my house, right? So anyway,
we were making this deal and I told him, I'm a
registered Republican, but I hate Trump and didn't
vote for him, by the way. That's true. You know, I
am a registered Republican. Anyway, I told the guy
this, and now that he thinks I'm a Republican, he
gave me the inside dirt like he's talking to his
own team and said he is so fearful that Trump is
going to run in 2024. And if Trump runs, they're
going to lose and they need to find somebody
better than Trump because Biden is sick and Harris
is horrible, and they're going to get nobody on
the Dem side, but whoever they get is going to
beat Trump. So they need to replace this guy was
a terrified Republican conservative who thinks
the world is falling is caving in, and he thinks
radical left wingers are taking over everything.
So they're scared, Dave. And it was neat to hear
this guy talk to me like I was on his own side.
It was really, really eye-opening and interesting.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think what the thing
to think about here is, it's there.
There's no exciting person on the
Democratic side right now. I mean,
Speaker 2: you know, let's let's
be honest. Joe Biden running for
Speaker 1: reelection isn't exciting,
and I don't know if he will win. Joe
Biden not running and it being Kamala
Speaker 2: Harris is not
Speaker 1: exciting, and I don't know
that she will win. There's not really
Speaker 2: excitement and you
Speaker 1: guys know that I
just in general and not super
Speaker 2: impressed with politicians anyway.
Speaker 1: They're just people
Speaker 2: at the end of the
day. But there's no one that's
Speaker 1: exciting me on the Democratic side,
on the Republican side. You have the deep,
devoted Trump cultists who
Speaker 2: still
Speaker 1: are completely on his side. But you
also have what the Egg Man is describing here
people who believe Trump's time has come and gone
Speaker 2: and that Trump will
Speaker 1: run again due to narcissism and
lose. And they don't know who to point to,
either. And I think this is why Ron
DeSantis, his name keeps coming up.
Speaker 2: He's competent in the sense
Speaker 1: of being able to
keep it together. He has Trump been in a lot of
his ideology and maybe more dangerously effective
at being able to get a lot of that stuff done.
But it is interesting that other than DeSantis,
the people, the names you hear mentioned by the
right, like more traditional Republicans, I don't
think they have a chance. I think the Republican
electorate has moved beyond sort of a traditional
Republican at this point in time. And that's
why you say, well, if it's got to be Trumpian.
But less whacked and maybe younger. That's
why the DeSantis possibility keeps coming up,
so we're going to wait and see.
On today's bonus show, we will
talk about Joe Biden's federal contractor
vaccine mandate being blocked by a judge.
We will talk about the legalization of suicide
pods in Switzerland, and we will also talk about
the bill backed by progressives
Speaker 2: in Congress for a four
Speaker 1: day workweek. What is the chance
Speaker 2: that this passes all of
Speaker 1: those stories and more on today's
bonus show? Sign up and join ActionScript.